what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible now this one is
a really really really cool story right
so here's the idea behind this in the
aftermath of mark basically being
poisoned by the scourge virus we're kind
of left with this situation where he
simply just recovering and so what we
actually end up doing is picking up with
a guy named zandale as he goes to hang
out with the taylor now as you guys know
the taylor is the one who designs
costumes for people and was actually
banging mark's mom for a little while
when uh when omniman when nolan had like
left earth right so they were kind of
you know touching naughty bits for a
little bit while she was coping with the
loss of her husband or her ex-husband
and so zandale kind of actually tells
him like i'm here because essentially
black samson kind of sent me right and
it's one of those funny things where he
makes this joke he's like are you
assuming his black samson because i'm
black right just kind of like a little
bit of a joke going on there but we
actually end up finding out that he's
the green ghost and that he's actually
the second iteration of the green ghost
that the first one basically died and
he's essentially taken his place now the
way that kirkman plays this the green
ghost really seems to be just kind of
analogous to like the the green lantern
right he says like he like the taylor
never had to make a costume for green
ghost because his quote unquote jade jim
did that for him right so essentially he
seemed more kindle like like a green
lantern than anything else but because
of the fact that zandale had helped
black samson with various missions and
things like that he sends him to the
tailor to basically get a costume so we
can essentially do the kind of superhero
thing for himself and so the result of
this is that he initially wants the
costume that the tailor is working on
that of course is going to go to mark
and taylor's like nah it's not going to
happen but you could take that one over
there right i mean the discs basically
allow you to store solar energy but
because your powers don't work that way
they just look cool like they're more of
a fashion thing and so at that point you
switch over to the dark side of the moon
right and you basically got like the
guardians of the globe and you've got
like adam eve and all these people who
were basically there
while mark's being treated now this is
also the first time that you end up
having freddie mercury meeting cecil and
it's kind of a funny thing right because
cecil as you guys know is kind of
charged with like protecting the world
and like freddie mercury doesn't want to
have any of that right like he's not
he's not playing politics or anything
along those lines because he's first
question is like how like like how did
you get here right like how how are you
here like we literally have an orbital
satellite system designed to basically
protect this world uh and to monitor
everything out there how did your ships
get past us and the response of freddie
mercury is like our ships got past you
because like we didn't want you to know
we were here we've been here for months
right and we will stay here like you
will honor the agreement that we've made
with mark one because it's the right
thing to do and two because you don't
have a choice there's nothing you can do
to stop us right if you set your
guardians of the globe against us we
would kill them all quite readily right
there's nothing that your guardians
could do to basically defeat us so uh
you just gotta learn to play ball man
but the other part of this and this is
one of the more sensitive aspects of
freddie mercury if he even has one is he
says like at the end of the day they
will coexist with everyone because if
they were to have a big fight here on
earth it would draw the coalition of
worlds and as you guys know from the
last video that we did the coalition of
worlds has to basically believe that the
viltrumites will not return to their
ways of trying to like conquer the
universe or anything like that that they
can actually live to live in peace the
whole thing rests on a knife set and the
response of freddie mercury gives here
is if the coalition of worlds comes to
the conclusion that we as a race cannot
be trusted they will come here against
the wishes of of allen alien and they
will kill all of us and likely do the
same thing to you like this virus is
affecting mark they'll spread it across
the world and it could very well lead to
the extinction of your people and so
he's like as to our current situation
we've dealt with the scourge virus
before we know how to handle it he says
that march life rests in their hands the
bigger problem with this is that one
this is a new variant of the the scourge
virus right it's like mark has coveted
it's a new strain of the virus so they
don't exactly know how it's supposed to
work they don't know how to treat this
the same way they knew how to treat the
previous version and that mark's still
in the early stages his condition will
get worse before it gets better and so
in a a kind of display i wouldn't say
solidarity but in a genuine display of
concern on behalf of cecil he's like
please do everything you can and that's
one of the easy things to forget when it
comes to the character of cecil is he a
crotchety old dick yeah like the guy's a
jerk man like he's just he's just kind
of hardcore in all honesty he kind of
trounces around a little too big for his
britches but it's also easy to forget he
genuinely cares about mark right it's
not as though he doesn't care about mark
at all that mark is some kind of a means
to an end or anything along those lines
for him it's his job to protect the
world and he'll do it by any means
necessary but he's not like some kind of
psychopath or sociopath he's not without
empathy so it's kind of cool to see this
this little bit of an exchange going on
here now at that point you switch over
to dinosaurs and then you basically have
him fighting alan the alien and the
reason why is because it's just a giant
misunderstanding
that basically what had happened when
mark was initially infected before they
whisked him off to the moon that he told
allen go find dinosaurs right the guy's
a scientific genius go find him he'll be
able to help us deal with this and so as
soon as alan the alien showed up
dinosaurs immediately attacked him and
like they just got into this big fight
you don't really get to see the fight
happen which is kind of disappointing
because i would love to have seen like
dinosaurs and alan allen alien get into
a fight with each other i feel like it
would have been amazing and i hope we
get it in the show but ultimately they
come to terms pretty fast right remember
like dinosaurs is a really really really
smart guy and somebody's like okay so
obviously mark sent you here yeah i
overreacted i apologize for that uh yeah
take me to mark allen's like i'll
explain everything on the way but but
dinosaurs like take me to mark right get
me to where mark's at one of the funny
things here though is that alan the
alien largely assumed that dinosaurs
could breathe in space because he could
breathe in space and so literally he
flies him into the vacuum of space and
then like dinosaurs just kind of start
suffocating and barely makes it right
and it's like damn like my bad man i i
thought i thought i assumed you could
breathe in space like mark can hold his
breath in space i assumed you were all
kind of like that and so when dinosaur
shows up here you immediately have the
guardians of the globe who like step in
right and they're almost kind of ready
to like launch an attack the villager
might step up as well and so what it
looks like here is they're all basically
aware of the nature of dinosaurs now the
viltrumites we kind of know they already
know because they've been here long
enough to know the kind of things that
like markers of vigilante that like
dinosaurs basically led to the
destruction of las vegas all that kind
of stuff so they were kind of here for
all of that and the guardians of the
globe responded to all that kind of
stuff right so right off the bat
dinosaurs is just not really an ally and
even freddie mercury is like no like
like your services are not needed here
right like we don't need you you don't
understand any of our technology or any
of our stuff right you it doesn't matter
and the response that dinosaurs makes is
actually wildly cool here right so he
says from what i know of your people and
your relationship to earth the only
possible reason you would even attempt
to cure invincible would be to gain
favor with the people of earth logically
you would not attempt to gain that favor
if you didn't deem it absolutely
essential to do so and so he says i'm
offering my assistance because
invincible is useful to me can you
really afford to turn away somebody who
is more than likely able to help and
that is a is an accurate statement
because if mark were to die and word got
out which it would somebody would leak
somewhere right that mark got out
because an alien came to earth to
destroy the vulture might race that's
living among them and mark was infected
in a bit of a skirmish everybody would
look to the viltrumites is the reason
for why all this happened in the first
place things would pop off like that it
would it would happen so quickly and so
because of that ultimately freddie
mercury is like okay fine like we can't
we can't turn this guy away essentially
like find a place for this guy to work
and then he tells the rest of them leave
right like get out of here right there's
nothing for you to do here we are hard
at work on this situation having you
here is only complicating things he says
our location will not change you can
return to visit at any time and when
alan's like i mean you can't really
expect us to leave here can you the
response of freddie mercury is like if i
wanted him dead he'd be dead already i
will not ask again leave right and alan
the alien is smart enough to know okay
we should leave
[Laughter]
he's smart enough to not cause problems
with with freddie mercury now this is
one of the most important moments in
this story right one of the most really
for like the future of the entire
invincible series what you have is thrag
who ends up visiting one of the
scientists right freddie mercury visited
one of the scientists and he says he
just discovered something extraordinary
and when freddie mercury asks like have
you discovered a cure he says no sadly
but during the process of trying to
synthesize a cure we drew samples of the
subject's dna thankfully it appears his
body is staving off the scourge virus
for now at least but that's not the
interesting part right this is important
he says i don't really know how to say
this but when we ran his dna he's a
match the immediate response of freddie
mercury is you are to tell no one do you
understand like do not tell anybody and
like like no one can know you know where
the scientist is kind of like i mean you
know i kind of feel like people should
know freddie mercury kills him right
he's like i'm sorry no one can know this
no one can know that that this is the
case like no one can have this
information this is one of the single
most important moments from the entirety
of the invincible run right those guys
who know please don't spoil it down in
the comments section it's a huge deal
and so you end up picking up with
zandale meeting with adam eve and the
whole thing behind this i mean initially
when this happened i was like damn dude
zandal's trying to like man he's trying
to get out of me between them between
the sheets right and it ends up turning
out that like she had kind of called him
here and the reason why is because of
the fact that with mark being out
remember they have invincible inc which
is basically like their own little
organization between adam even mark as
well as a few other people they've
recruited that serve the purpose of like
safeguarding different places right
sometimes it's bodyguard duty sometimes
it's like defeating some villains that
are like destroying a thing or something
like that never really anything
nefarious right if some organization's
like mark i need you to go and topple
that you know legitimately elected you
know political official over there so
that i can build solar panels in in his
backyard you know i mean they're not
going to do that right that's that's not
going to happen but uh because of the
fact that mark's not here and because of
the fact that mark is m.i.a kind of
believed to possibly be on the verge of
death that much like you would expect
with like a company that looked like he
was about to go belly up clients are
pulling out because why would you keep
your horse hitched to a stable that
looks like it's getting ready to just be
destroyed and so this is one of the few
one of the last few clients they have
left and there's just some things
popping off the other part of this is
that zandale had stepped in and helped
with invincible inc while mark was out
in space the problem with this is that
when the companies contracted with
invincible incorporated they were paying
for marks services they were not paying
for the services of zandale and so while
he did exactly what was supposed to be
done in order to basically save the day
that their stance is no they paid for
invincible they want refunds right they
basically didn't get exactly what they
paid for or they didn't get the person
that they paid for and so as a result of
this zandel's idea is like okay i have
an idea right if i stay stay like a
little bit further away um and they
can't really see me up close i think we
can pull this off and so what he ends up
doing is going to the tailor and
basically like he gets a haircut and
then he gets a new costume and he
basically passes himself off
as the black version of invincible but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace
you